[Music]
hector mejía greets you with the headlines
for today thursday december 24 the
man accused of running over and killing
five cyclists near searchlight was
transferred from a jail in arizona to
the clark tour county detention center
in paris in 45 years  faces 12
charges for crimes that include
drunk driving bardem had a hearing
scheduled today but he is in
quarantine according to a report
he had methamphetamine in his system
on the day of the crash valley medical centers
continue to receive
the coronavirus vaccine three thousand doses of the
very hard vaccine arrived at the
johns hospital and on Wednesday so far the
hospital has vaccinated more than 2,000
members of its workforce with the
vaccine manufactured by the
pfiezer pharmaceutical official added that the
vaccinations to its employees will continue
these coming weeks more shipments are expected
on  January 4 and several
testing sites for the detection of the
coronavirus have changed
operating bios the only sites open
today christmas eve is
the southern nevada health district also the
del carmen ser all sites will be
closed tomorrow christmas day the
testing center at taxi station opens
on saturday and the free program  for
Christmas tree recycling it will be
open starting this coming Saturday it
is located at the sprint sprint service
will remain open until
January 15th please remove all
decorations from your tree also the
program does not accept artificial snow trees
yes  you can't physically go you can
call the buffet service that
delivers for 25 bucks and santa claus
is pretty busy this christmas eve on
his trip for sure you will face
various temperatures there will be
cloudy skies over the desert southwest
and a cold christmas with temperatures in
the 30 yes cloudy skies today
a high of 53 is anticipated
happy christmas eve I am héctor mejía and
this was his  Brief information about them
in Spanish
[Music]